know obviously this game is really
reviewing strongly right the open critic
is out there i believe it's still on
what is it the highest rating game of um
excuse me yeah look at it right now with
over 30 reviews so far forza horizon 5
is currently the highest rated game of
2020. then we've seen the metacritic i
believe it came in about
1991 which i'm looking at right now it's
getting extremely positive reviews
especially on um streaming a great
mobile streaming game because of the
accessibility you know graphical
fidelity ease of access all that stuff
so the question i bring to this
beautiful panel today at the round table
is um
can
a racing game
be nominated and win game of the year
yeah
is it possible it is forza horizon 5
the one that could do it let me just let
me let me speak to this just real quick
let's go because i have such an issue
with the game of the year
here's the thing if it can't the person
should never ever be allowed to do a
game of the year it's called game of the
year
game of the year that's all games and if
that person cannot say that this
particular game is not a game and can't
be nominated for game of the year then
we have completely broken the entire way
in which we cover games now
that is so
wrong
that is so wrong and it's not even
because it's forza i would say it i gave
game of the year to some weird games in
the last couple of years
and
and if anybody had the audacity to tell
me that that's that can't be game of the
year because of whatever like a walking
time
simulator ethan carter one of my
favorite games if somebody said that
couldn't be game of the year i'd be like
dude you're gone like why are we even
talking about let's get it let's dive
deeper now let's
love that you said i just want to push
but i don't even push back i want to ask
you what they so because of what you
said how strongly you said it right
the question is why
is the racing genre
in your opinion
like limited to even now to the point
ever born and we'll see stuff like that
we'll see racing and sports combined
into one award
so the question is why what is the
mindset
that a game
can't win it like what what do you think
they're thinking
who cannot be flexible in changing with
the environment yeah
old people can not be flexible and
changing and don't realize that that can
be a game of the year because i'm going
to tell you right now what is an
eight-hour game that's got some story
how can that be game of the year if a
game that offers 70 hours making your
own blueprints doing your own tunes your
own vinyls 3 000 layers of vinyls dude
i've seen people do vinyl stuff that
makes me want to cry because i have no
talent
i can make a square on the side of my
car at best and these dudes make homer
simpson like and it looks like perfect
right so those people are people who do
not share the flexibility and are not
understanding that games are dynamic
compared to what they used to be it used
to be just a couple games right and a
couple genres now we have an open world
remember when games you couldn't even
get out of the car yes it would be a
racing game and it's like you can't get
out of the car because the graphics
engine could not do it right now gta is
here
it all all bets are off no doubt
everyone is about to jump here
yeah so uh on on the um game awards
point yes um i i always find interesting
the dichotomy between the game awards
and the academy awards right
now every year
uh at the academy awards
the the big budget franchise
generally safe movies tentpole four
quadrant movies
those are the films that
may not even get nominated they always
win the technical awards but they never
win the big prize
right
but they usually geared towards the more
uh original typically lower budget uh
more creative
projects
now
it's interesting to me that on the flip
side with video games and the video game
awards there's always an obligatory
indie game that gets nominated but it's
really only the big budget
uh 50 million hundred million dollar
four quadrant game that gets nominated
and it's sort of like so the oscars
shuns the popcorn movies and the video
game
industry uh praises them and i always
wondered why that is
and what does that say about those
awards can you chop it at the bit and
then i'm going to open it up to king and
solve it no it's
um
it's subjective okay you know
to be honest with you uh
every game is worthy of game of the year
right that's door's my game of the year
still right now i i didn't get a chance
to play yet it's not on game pass
shout out to the king's rating system
passes
ever born you ain't seen this food this
man be eating he spends like a rack this
time
we see that spread i don't
dollars on butter for the lobster that
he gets
but he ain't paying attention
that is definitely a fraud alert i would
have to agree i have a boy continue
[Laughter]
see again again there you go pocket
watch
you see what it says
i want you to partake in greatness and
not the marketing greatness yes but the
death story greatness that's all i'm
saying a lot of pocket ones okay though
it's okay though everborn because
usually when it comes to these indie
games man we pick up a couple to give
away so we balance it out yeah it's all
good continue get to your
kids
i have a theory we'll go to game pass
the day it launches on playstation in
november later this month and i'll play
it there um
continue the fact that these games are
subjective you know like it's it's what
do you view as game of the year is what
you view as a game of the year but these
people that are in control if they say
that oh this game doesn't uh
like reach certain criteria i thought it
was game of the year the object word
there that word there is game right so
if it's a game it's worthy to be put as
game of the year right so a racing game
forza can be game of the year because it
is a game you down with it i don't care
if it's a a phone game a mobile game
people have a lot of problems when um
what was that game that y'all had a
problem with
and it was the multiplayer game oh you
mean the one that was in my feeling
you call you coming for me
no no i'm glad you brought that up
because the game that we king is talking
about is uh overwatch and i watched a
great game right and i i just found it
funny that the same people who would
gatekeep game of the year for other type
of experiences that didn't have a
narrative those are the things i really
gotta have a narrative you gotta have
this you gotta have that and i when i
found out that overwatch didn't have
that right which no disrespect over i
just thought it was funny so that's why
i'm like oh so now that we know that you
know for the horizon and other games of
different genres that sometimes don't
have narrative but have these other
great experiences is it okay now is it
okay now for those people who are
gatekeeping and trying to keep certain
games out of this mythical championship
title domination
are we fully now open-minded to include
everything that's what i was going out
with i'm an anti-award show right yeah i
know you all i know you you don't want
nobody to tell you how to eat your food
i know i always you're not going to tell
me what was good or what sounded great
or whatever
i
they give game of the year to games that
aren't out yeah
like look at some of those trailer stuff
will be like game of the year award and
you'll look at it you'll be like that
game's not out here
game of the year
in october guys there's a couple extra
months like what calendar are they using
it's just oh
i would just like to see this year halo
infinite uh get it because they bent the
rules and allow it in and then win
just to eat popcorn and watch the world
the people who do do like a lot of the
behind the scenes for what gets
dominated and what not like there are
going to be it looks like some
conflictions like i don't know
if it's like conflictions i don't know
everything going on there i'm just state
i don't know the process behind all this
stuff uh but like to me when especially
when it comes to game of the year i've
always felt like to me the reason like
game of the year
i've always felt like that game that not
necessarily was the best of the year but
pushed the industry the most of the year
like overwatch that game came out that
year had its own uh had its own car like
almost out the gate like i remember
it being like a phenomenal like sir it
was only a multiplayer center game but
everyone was talking about this game
like and i've always felt like we can't
have one and not the other like people
say that's what i'm saying single player
games got to be a game of the year and
i'm like that's not fair because if it's
a strictly multiplayer game but it is
the kind of the level and the kind of
like move the the needle forward because
i don't necessarily because i wasn't
paying attention to trains and stuff
back then but overwatch i felt like push
that um it was so dominant in that thing
that it kind of
killed hero shooters in its own way
because it's like yeah we can't compete
with overwatch so
like uh
yeah well he tried yeah
law breakers yeah
what exactly happened to bleeding edge
like why did it just coming nobody
played it
it was really bland really yeah i felt
like they had a great concept they just
didn't build the walls so the walls fell
down like i i really i really feel like
if they would have actually i'm not
saying that you know the game was doomed
to the game was going to come out if
microsoft didn't let it come out right
because i don't think they would have
finished it uh because of the way things
were going over there but it's just like
i've i love bleeding edge like i like
the way they did it i like it's yeah the
art design was good i just felt like you
know the core
of bleeding edge was good it's just they
needed to build around it better than
they did they needed more maps coming up
more content coming out they needed to
keep people in there and i just felt
like that's where they failed you know
uh what was that other game that came
out with overwatch that people were
comparing the gigantic oh i know what
you're talking about it was a good game
too
there was another one that was kind of
supposed to be the overwatch video it
was made by uh i know it was remember
that people make borderlands oh you
don't hurt me like i said i actually
like it more than overwatch i know the
game you're talking about um
it was uh
battleborn battle battle i actually
really like
situations like bad words like i was
saying like overwatch was so dominant
when it came to its brand and how it ran
in its part of that genre that anything
around it
couldn't even get on the mountain and
that's why i feel like you know in terms
of that game yeah uh there's a reason it
got
restructure how they gameplay the game
of the year stuff
i feel like sometimes it does go to you
know a friend of a friend i don't even
necessarily think it's a friend of a
friend or anything like that but i do
think there are some things that don't
make sense when stuff happens right and
like you know we were talking about the
like the indie game getting nominated
for game of the year it's like are they
nominating that game because they do
feel like it deserves to be there are
they doing it because they're throwing
the indy market a bone and like to me i
don't mind if stuff is there if it
deserves to be there and i'm not saying
the indie games haven't deserved to be
there right but it's like if you're
going to throw an indie developer a bone
i feel like that's more disrespectful
because you're giving them that spot
because you feel like you know you have
to for the indie scene then give them
that spot because they deserve to be in
that scene if that makes sense to you
you don't understand on some level
because to me and that's
to me that setting that indy developer
up to fail because you know they're not
going to beat the competition but you're
putting them in there because you feel
like you haven't mentioned them
on the list
but no no addict is right attic is right
and and i've been saying this for years
they do an obligatory indie game
nomination every year and ask yourself
when has it the indie game ever won
but i think i think putting the
spotlight on it is
in a lot of ways helps a lot i don't
know if it's studying you know i don't
think it's setting them up to fail
because it's putting them on the
platform and then remember like
and i'll get into this when i start
talking it's it's you're up now each of
no no no
every category there's categories that
specify those games right so for that
game to sort of
punch above his weight and and be in
that category in addition to game of the
year
i think those are eyes on that game that
would not have been there otherwise so i
don't know about the failure part i
don't get that well it's it's it's not
that you know that's free promotion so
that you know maybe you're right on that
uh they are getting that free promotion
i would say like one of the the
exceptions to something like hades like
hades was transistor so when you see
those type of games go up there you were
like okay i understand that but
sometimes the years be stacked y'all you
can't we can't admit that and then you
see this random indie game that he's
like yo that was good
better than this
i want to get solved get back on focus
and vote for move on with fours again
with four's this off
yes because we can't we're all over the
place and we got to get back to the
to the final thing no it's good it's
good bro it was a good discussion i
didn't want to stop it this was a good
organic discussion but on saw like we
talked about again the game of the year
thing you know is forza horizon i know
you haven't got a chance to play i'm
assuming you're gonna get a chance no no
idea i don't know
oh he's playing
are you part of the million that's
playing right now that's over one dollar
game pass really i did that that's
i played that 40 game past spring room
to get a whole bunch of like cars and
whatever i forgot what it was right is
all that stuff earnable inside the game
probably if you play long enough yeah
probably yeah for sure you just want to
jump the line no this is not this is not
i'm not paying to win i'm not paying to
win you know what i'm saying i love i
love how king is praying about
everything but when it comes to buying
preachers yeah
[Laughter]
before i leave i do uh you know solve uh
once you get the i do want to talk about
like yeah the the stuff going on with
like the game yeah let's get it so let's
get started
we got to get that into that it's a good
question so when it comes to
uh the game of the year discussion yes
that's
to acg's point i think the game really
the game of your discussion is broken
already it's been broken right because
when you start
when keeley decides to do his
awards right which are the ones that
people most people consider the main
ones whatever the case may be when
you're not doing them in january or
february
and you're omitting a good amount of
games that come out mid-november through
december
it's a problem it's a problem because
you're admitting they've been games like
uh jedi fallen order right what else
yeah
in this year's case in this year from
what i've heard it's going to be halo
it's going to be
i think foreign
apparently misses the cut for the kiwis
really
oh i didn't know that i'm not sure do
you think they should do it at the
beginning of the every year
absolutely they do it like january
february
yeah absolutely they have to they should
do it that way that way you gave all the
games that come out in that calendar
year yeah it's called game of the year
exactly
how do you omit a good amount of games
and it's not like it used to be that you
know past november whatever 15th or
whatever you're not getting game
releases right game releases happen
every single month of the year now every
time is a good time to release the game
so for me that process is broken in and
of itself right okay a second thing is
that you give people a pass when you
have specific tiers and categories for
these specific types of games
as their own sort of game of the year in
that category and then you get people
passively like well if it's here then it
shouldn't be here it won't be here and
then when you look at that game within
your discussion you have a lot of
third-person over-the-shoulder action
adventure games it's the same type of
game all the time right and people have
this assumption about that it has to be
narrative driven it has to be this super
moving game and a lot of times right not
no no i don't say a lot of times that's
that's too much right but there are
times that
the idea of playing the game gameplay
falls to the wayside in lieu of in lieu
of
aaa production value or whatever the
case may be a lot of times that happens
right um
a year that i it didn't happen without
surprise and for me it was sakura right
i picked second row and i was like
second row to me is the greatest playing
game this entire year right but because
of it because it's niche
and resp
compared to a lot of other games that
nominated i was like i don't know who's
gonna do it right and it did it and i
was like oh my god i can't believe this
happened another time
it definitely deserved it right um so
for me
forza horizon 5 as it stands right now
and if by the end of the year this game
still i don't really care about
metacritic i don't know but it is a good
way just to aggregate numbers right do
you see the number if the aggregate of
this game is above all other games
and it doesn't and it doesn't have a
real shot at winning game of the year
there is a big problem
there is a big problem because this game
i think what horizon does
that
it gives you the open world formula that
a ubisoft game does right because it
does the same thing it has all the check
boxes it has all the things on the map
it's like oh my god i have too much
stuff to do
but the way that it breaks it down it
allows you to take it in bits and pieces
pause
it allows you to play the game in bits
and pieces
in a way
that those games do very well right if
there's anything i would change about
forza in terms of the formula after now
the fifth one yeah is
make the narrative stuff more important
right yeah maybe maybe the horizon
festival in and of itself could take a
little bit of a break right because it's
that same format right but in terms of
how they break down the open world for
you and in terms of how you engage with
that open world the different things i
think it does that perfectly and
beautifully and five is the is the
exemplification of that it is the
perfection of that it's ubisoft games
done
done done fun right it really is where
is that that repeatable task that you're
doing
is is different from moment to moment
enough so it's it's just continuously
fun to do and then when you look at the
game that runs and looks so beautiful
it's easy to stay in that world so for
me
if this game does not appear in point
blank game of the year discussion
you're going to boycott them
foreign